commandant michel bourbon jour bonjour
l'été arrive
est ce que montréal est encore
considérée comme la capitale du sexe la
capture de la prostitution au canada
c'est difficile de dire vraiment que
montréal est le capitaine chaix ce que
je pourrais vous dire c'est que montréal
comme tout burqa en grandes villes
nord-américaines européen attire c'est
certainement son look doivent de
services sexuels à différents niveaux
ce qu'on peut voir présentement c'est
vraiment que à terme de l'exploitation
sexuelle c'est vraiment qui nous sur
lesquels on regarde vraiment donc les
jeunes qui peuvent être entraînés dans
des réseaux de prostitution des réseaux
qui vous diraient ils les utilisent en
fait pour éventuellement offrir des
services sexuels c'est quelque chose
malheureusement qui est en demande
surtout sexuelle mineurs est ce qu on
veut regarder vraiment c'est contré ses
efforts
maintenant on leur établi depuis quand
même quelques années une augmentation au
niveau des effectifs en qualité et en
matière de préparation pour justement
prévenir et surtout dénoncer et de nine
la venue de demain aux gens ou qu'on
puisse contrecarrer ce phénomène qui se
prostituent est-ce que c'est
essentiellement des québécoises où c'est
des gens c'est la traite des personnes
la des jeunes qui arrivent sans avec
dépasse pas on leur enlève l'épreuve
parce que c'est des phénomènes kenzy
symbole c'est vraiment considéré comme
un phénomène domestique autre maladie
est un phénomène de personnes issues du
milieu québécois
donc ça peut provenir des régions pour
premier de montréal il n'y a pas
vraiment de tendance qu'on a vu de gens
qui proviendraient par exemple européens
de l'est avec provient de l'émission où
est ce qu'ils se retrouvent dans des
réseaux comme ça c'est launière
résignèrent c'est pas vraiment un
phénomène qu'on voyait seulement ils
sont des québécois si des québécois
ordinaire colis aux mineurs écoutez ce
qu'on regarde dans les entrevues dans
qu'est ce qu'on fait les gens qu'on
essaye de table et quelles sont leurs
statuts seront témoins sur victimes à
peu près lever 20 à 25 % sont des
mineurs mais ça me poser non plus qu'ils
n'ont pas travaillé
maintenant si on les raconte à l'âge
adulte qui on peut travailler dans ce
milieu là même aux débutants qu'aux
mineurs donc c'est pour ça que je me
suis une statistique est un petit peu
grise de ce niveau qui sont les clients
ne les gens peut-être croient que parce
que bon le grand prix carrie festival de
jazz
beaucoup de touristes qui arrivent à
montréal ce sont des touristes est-ce
que c'est plus de tourisme de québécois
écoutent et au niveau de la clientèle ce
qu'on te voit présentement c'est
beaucoup québécois quand il ya plus de
personnes ici au québec par exemple à
l'oréal pour des grappes et des grains
de riz rassemblement c'est sûr qu'à ce
moment là il ya toujours un potentiel
pilote de grand prix qui veut dire
qu'ils animent montréal c'est la cour
tous les meilleurs bande de danseurs je
peux vous dire est ce est en train de
changer parce que montréal présentement
une diminution
quand on parle de bars de danseuses je
regarde un peu les chiffres les rendus
pour le passé une quarantaine
d'établissements présent chiffre exact
mais ce qu'on voit c'est vraiment une
diminution à ce niveau là les clubs de
danseuses oui atteint une certaine
clientèle c'est est en train de changer
c'est une question de culture aussi là
dedans faut dire que menad plus qu'on en
parle plus que la population réalise
aussi que le repos il ya des gens qui
sont possiblement exporté à travers ce
mulot oui puis vous parlez d'exploiter
un pimp ça peut faire convictions
personnelles
écoutez les rhinos a peut être certaines
dollars 200 $ $ pour une personne qui
demande un service sexuel mais si vous
mettez les pieds sur par 10 15 personnes
cuillère qui vont être en contact avec
cette personne là ça peut devenir terme
et des montants assez important est ce
que les lois sont assez sévères le
fédéral avait changé sa loi ça passait
pas encore promulguée on voulait rendre
plus facile la condamnation d une est ce
que vous vous les arrêter ils ont su des
sentences bonbons
on a l'impression qu'on n'est pas assez
dur avec eux je dirais qu'à présent
demain dans le registre le dense on voit
une recrudescence en matière de sentence
et sentence on essaie naturellement dans
la possibilité de pouvoir des sentences
sont plus importants mais présentement
ccpo rare qu'on voit des sentences de 4
ans et quand c'est en 1900 à québec
dernièrement l'onu d'accusation donc
c'est à dire le système judiciaire est
plus dure on s'adapte on s'adapte est
aussi faux que les à la police turque
avant d'établir meilleure preuve donc
c'est ce qu'on fait présentement en
ligne preuve qu'ils plus soutenue c'est
pour juste la déclaration des jeunes là
c'est vraiment des éléments de
collaboration qui vont venir établir un
peu le contexte comment ça s'est produit
que c'est arrivé et pour acheminer les
gens qui est de l'autre donc vous êtes à
la hauteur de la tâche vous les achats
liés à ces l'epim peut tout à fait y est
on le voit on le voit aussi dans ces
circonstances le département des ti
médiation parce que c'est un phénomène
qu'on vaut aussi à l'intérieur de deux
procédures judiciaires on le voit que
les accusés ou déjà que peuvent-elles
parc au niveau de connivence avec eux
vont essayer jeté vers 2
d'influencé des victimes donc ça veut
dire qu'on leur fait mal donc on
transmet un message clair qu'on va
s'ouvrir aux victimes qu'on va devenir
nous nogent market pour arriver à
l'aboutissement de knockout et là vous
visez il ya un programme que vous mettez
sur pied radars oui tout à fait vous
visez les gens des hôtels des
restaurants quand ils sont tes mots vous
voulez que soit plus éveillés à la
présence de pim
en fait c'est vraiment un travail de
collaboration ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
s'est associé avec les deux services de
deux autres grands services de la région
de montréal donc laval et longueuil pour
travail y est l'association hôtelière du
grand montréal le bureau du taxi est
aussi également deux organismes comme un
génie soleil info crime et aussi des
services d aide aux victimes des crimes
et ce qu'on veut faire c'est vraiment
être capable de donner une capacité aux
gens d'amelio tellier d'avoir des
observations qui sont concrètes qui
portait par un lien avec l'exploitation
sexuelle à plivot coiffer dont ces
événements est incolore avec un numéro
de téléphone vont pour le gaz avant de
voir un plus bas de plus des affichettes
les gens vont marquer comme quoi que les
jeunes ici on qui travaillent ici les
employés que ce soit de toute nature que
ce soit aux tueries et forme de chant
commis à la réception ont été
sensibilisés l'exploitation sexuelle et
sont capables mais delà de dénoncer ces
assises ces informations aux lots à des
endroits comme par exemple servir aux
bolides directement soit de le faire
quand on a une personne devrait
clairement dargis ça peut être par le
fdf au crime dans lequel certaines voix
les anonymes aussi qui qui est pour nous
l'important c'est d'abord les cours
baissent il faut avoir clairement un
numéro de téléphone il va monter les
formes l'interface facile pour les
chauffeurs de taxi pour tout le monde
exactement le décès sûr que lorsqu'on
est une personne d'origine de france est
le premier pays où on se dit toujours
mieux vous rappeler que de ne pas
essayer quand même lorsque si appelons
appelons un faux créé ou aussi
naturellement les numéros long urgent
aussi pour le service de police peuvent
être utilisés pour un quartier natal au
commandant book dernière question est ce
que les policiers vous avez parlé de
longueuil laval
l'escouade conomie sur piles à estaires
l'équipe intégrée de la course et ça
fonctionne très bien digéré leur
l'important notre pauvre est parce qu
est ce qu on fait le cycle établi une
meilleure coordination à travers tous
les services policiers meilleur arquette
meilleure information tout ce qui est en
matière de renseignement transmission
par exemple d'une jeune femme donne un
exemple concret une jeune femme mettant
cap a dénoncé con sic et pat symonds et
piquet dans un réseau mais si on est
capable de parler nos partenaires potec
éventuels avoirs faire surface ailleurs
et à son mono est capable de transmettre
l'information la poche de l'un est berne
permettent la dénonciation pour
poursuivre et à ce moment là on préfère
le livre m'a pas dit si les infos
exactement aux pétitions actuellement
c'est vraiment il n'ya pas de
compétition mais là on peut faire le
plus de dossiers possibles on veut
vraiment contrecarrer ce phénomène la
dig aussi le hip hop a payé pour ses
soutiens non l eau soit par des on veut
répéter ce message nautique
il faut dénoncer et il va voir des gens
qui vont être là pour les aider des
policiers mais on a aussi des
travailleurs de rue des gens qui sont
des intervenants dans le milieu centre
jeunesse et aux qui sont là prête à les
entendre et écouter leurs données je
donne l'information nécessaire pour
poursuivre et après son voyage c'est sûr
avec la volonté de la personne mais une
chose qui est importante c'est fou les
sorties de ce mulot faut faire tout ce
qu'on est à pouvoir être tous nos
partenaires que ce soit dans le réseau
social réseaux palissy et tous les
autres partenaires et ce soit au début
puis limina l'autre la priorité c'est
les mineurs c'est sûr que là
préliminaire mais on le voit aussi
l'exploitation sexuelle ça ne me touche
pas jusque là leader déjà
peuvent donner dans les réseaux de large
adolescent adulte et donc à ce moment-là
nous faut vraiment aller chercher toute
la cour des populations qui peuvent être
affectés mots d'abord qu'à la prochaine
merci merci beaucoup sur web vous avez
besoin
[Musique]
vous aviez été très nombreux à nous
écrire sur ce problème de la
prostitution mineurs surtout à montréal
alors voilà la réponse de la police de
montréal j'avais un sujet nous soumettre
voici nos adresses n'hésitez pas patrice
roy un mot commercial radio tirer
canada.ca ou sur notre page facebook
barres obliques tj 18 h
[Musique]